[Musique]
c'est une drag queen de montréal après
s'être rendu en finale de la populaire
émission canada sera grèce rita vague a
effectué un retour triomphal dans le
village
accueilli par des fans fidèles qui ont
suivi avidement ses passages télé on
était en gagne dans la salle on
attendait juste un moment là a tout les
jeudis soirs finalement ce n'est ce pas
aussi cueille n'était fière d'être une
drag-queen francophone data ta capuche
et fort pour arriver wasquehal et puis
c'est une des actrices de marque de mort
est un espèce de fierté qu'on connaisse
le queens parce que je faisais sur
instagram gens suivaient beaucoup kinés
des états unis rentrée l'heure je me
suis dit je me rende jusqu'à la fin je
veux c'est montrer fièrement mes racines
québécoises de notre culture drague au
sein l'engagement pour les dragues c'est
pas quelque chose de nouveau
le simple fait de faire de la drag queen
est une flamboyante prises de position
sur la drague dès le départ ce stade ces
politiciens faut se rappeler aussi
quelqu'un ça commence et c'est surtout
des personnes trans crise et et des
draps gracieuse et aussi qu'ils étaient
au front depuis 2007 le soir rue tabaga
se produit sur scène mais le matin
jean-françois lièvremont son alter ego
travail au sein de l'organisme fierté
montréal
ça a commencé comme un lieu de
résistance après celle d'un
rassemblement et maintenant c'est plus
une destination mais depuis son passage
à canada's reds
que ce soit dans le village ou même à
calgary quand elles marchent dans la rue
sans maquillage
les gens s'arrêtent sur son passage déjà
son comptable quand ils me voient chez
projet ça les faisceaux auraient ils
sont comme elle ou son quota des femmes
et des collègues pierre inspirée elle
passe avec sa tête mais à l'ag avec son
coeur je pense que rita vraiment nous a
bien démontré comment la communauté et
c'est serré j'essaie de profiter de ma
plateforme pour élever des voies plus
marginalisées aussi de faire des choix
qui inclut les communautés de drague
locale
j'ai tellement fait longtemps partie de
spectacle parce que j'étais qu'une
première partie où un petit numéro entre
deux dragues vedette américaine que je
ne veux pas perpétuer ce sans doute et
dans le coeur de ses admirateurs en
cette rentrée
montréal le couronner une nouvelle queen
is in est bien lexandre charti radio
canada montréal